SPEAKER: We've covered
using Cloud monitoring
in your projects.
But what if you're responsible
for managing many projects,
and you need to unify
monitoring across them?
And how can you control
access to monitoring data
from many projects?
Today, we'll look at Cloud
monitoring metrics scopes,
and learn how to use them
to monitor multiple Cloud
projects.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
Let's start with
a simple example.
How can you make it easier
to view monitoring data
for multiple projects?
If I go to monitoring
settings for my project,
I can see that my current
metrics scope only
has a single project in it,
the one I'm currently viewing.
I can add others, but what's
actually happening here?
Let's have a look at metrics
scopes and how they work.
When you create a
Google Cloud project,
that project hosts
a metrics scope
and becomes the scoping
project for that scope.
It stores the alerts,
uptime checks, dashboards,
and monitoring groups that
you configure for the scope.
For example, if you create
a staging project and then
access monitoring, you
can see the metrics
for the resources in
the staging project.
This happens for every
project you create.
Each project creates a
metrics scope for itself,
and hosts monitoring
configuration for itself.
But what if you want to
centralize how that data is
stored and how it's accessed?
You can add multiple projects
to an existing scope.
Now, monitoring data for
all projects in that scope
will be visible.
This will let you do things
like create dashboards
showing resources from all
the projects in the scope,
or alerting policies
that apply to resources
in multiple projects as long as
they're in the metrics scope.
Note that the recommended
approach for production
deployments is to create a
dedicated project to host
monitoring configuration
data and use its metrics
scope to set up monitoring
for the projects that
have actual resources in them.
This way, should a project
not be necessary anymore
and get deleted, the
monitoring configuration
for all the other projects
won't be impacted.
What about access?
While in this
configuration, you just
must have appropriate
IAM permissions
to access monitoring data.
For example, a user would
need to have the right role
in the monitoring project
to be able to see monitoring
data for both projects.
A user who only has access
to the staging project
would not be able to
see any monitoring data
for the production project.
Now that you understand
what metrics scopes are
and what to use
them for, let's have
a look at how to set them
up in Cloud monitoring.
Let's start in our
staging project.
We'll go to Compute
Engine, and see that we
have a single VM running.
We can go to monitoring, and see
that monitoring data for the VM
is being shown.
For example, on the
infrastructure summary
dashboard.
Let's now go to our
monitoring project,
and confirm that there
aren't any compute instances
running in it.
We also don't have the
out-of-the-box compute
dashboards because we don't have
any resources running in this
project.
Let's now add our
staging project
to be monitored by
this metrics scope.
We can do that in monitoring
settings by adding a project,
selecting the project
we want to add,
and confirming that we
want to use this monitoring
project as the scoping
project rather than creating
a new scope.
Once this operation is
complete, monitoring data
from the staging project will be
visible in this metrics scope.
We can confirm that by going
to the VM instances dashboard,
for example.
From here, we can
see more details
about the instance being
monitored, even though it's
running in another project.
So that's how we can use the
Cloud Console to configure
metrics scopes and
collect monitoring
data for multiple projects.
So that's how to configure
metrics scopes in the UI.
But how can you figure
out where your project is
being monitored, or where the
monitoring data you can see
in your project is coming from?
Let's have a look.
Now that we have added
our staging project
to our monitoring
metrics scope, let's
see how we can navigate
between the two.
We can see information about
our current metrics scope
here on the monitoring overview
page for the monitoring
project.
If we click on that, we can
see that the monitoring project
is monitoring
metrics for resources
running in the project itself
and in our staging project.
We can go there
directly from here.
In the staging project,
we can do the same thing,
and see that this project is
monitoring metrics for itself,
and that it is being monitored
by our monitoring project.
And we can go back
to that project
simply by clicking on that link.
So that's how you can navigate
between metrics scopes
and monitored projects
in Cloud monitoring.
Navigating metrics scopes
in the UI is easy enough.
But how can you ensure that,
for example, new projects
are added to your Production
Monitoring configuration?
You can use the API
to automate that.
Let's have a look.
Let's start in
monitoring settings,
and confirm that this
particular metrics scope is only
monitoring this project,
which is the scoping
project for this metrics scope.
Now let's go to our API.
We'll use the Create method
for metrics scopes projects
which takes two arguments.
First one is the parent,
which is the metrics
scope that we want to add
our stage and project to.
The second is our
project itself,
which is a monitored
project resource.
The name field
includes a reference
to both the staging project
and the metrics scope
we're adding this project to.
Let's execute this request,
authenticate, and confirm
that the operation is done.
We can now go back to monitoring
settings for our monitoring
project, refresh the
page, and confirm
that the staging
project has been
added to this metrics scope.
So that's how you can
use the Cloud monitoring
API to manage how projects are
monitored by metrics scopes.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered how metrics
scopes lets you configure
monitoring across projects, and
how to manage them in the UI
and using the API.
I hope this helps you
standardize and automate
your monitoring, run
more reliable services,
and keep your users happy.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.